let's go to our next caller from the 918
area code caller what's your name and
where are you calling from yes a little
goo my name is a Phillips and bolsa
great what's on your mind uh well I'm
mostly angry about how well with with
the camps well not necessarily campaign
anymore but with the administration and
how they're sort of giving tips towards
other judicial branches about how they
should investigate themselves yeah and I
I don't appreciate that one bit it's
like it's like how chunk might give a
phone call or some staff for my given
phone call to a court then hey we don't
really mean that or Trump calling me
head of the FBI okay you think you can
monitor my White House correspondent
phone calls because you know you should
investigate this you should investigate
this and not investigate what you're
currently investigating cuz you know why
not you know yeah we're getting our air
show do this okay what are you getting
any or something I've talked about which
is the what I've dubbed a regressive
populist authoritarian tendencies of
Trump a key aspect of that is the
blurring of weakening of or elimination
of the checks and balances and
separations of power that are sort of
like a key aspect of the United States
of America and how government is
supposed to operate and you're
absolutely right i mean the the request
and it seems like spicer Sean Spicer the
White House press secretary orchestrated
this request to the FBI to come out and
say hey there's no Russia stuff or
whatever whatever the case was that that
he wanted them to say yet there's no
boundaries right now and the worst part
of it is the following number one the
supposedly Constitution loving trumpets
there's basically silent on this because
they will
leave that the means justify the ends
they believe that we need the so-called
drain the swamp outsider which Donald
Trump is not they believe we need
exactly what it is that Donald Trump is
doing they're not complaining about what
it is that's going on and House
Republicans and Senate Republicans who
at least for now are hoping to ride the
Trump train into re-election in 28 10
2018 they're not going to call it out
you hear a couple people Lindsey Graham
has expressed concern John McCain has
expressed some concern but by and large
unless Trump's approval rating gets into
the mid-20s where Republicans start
jumping ship there's not going to be
anybody to call Trump out on this stuff
and I agree with you it's dangerous I
just want to say this in the most
simplest terms like what if I like a
police officer or an investigator was
investigating you yeah for crime that
you may or may not have committed but
then you call me and say hey why don't
you look in the storage box because this
storage box might have something against
the other person yeah be prosecuting
instead of me absolutely why is
completely unethical that is the
simplest term that I'm putting out but
it's exactly what is happening here and
I can't stand for it I'm just going
crazy here everyday guy here's something
new and it's like your way up every day
is 364 a.m. or roughly that time
something crazy happens I i I'm on board
with you I really appreciate the call
share your frustration for sure and you
know we'll keep reporting on it that's
one thing that that we can do let's talk
against you and appreciate the call